hey ernie a friend of mine tracy asked
me a question who's tracy theresa uh her
dad coaches saint joe's jim boyle one of
the great man i've ever met in my life
uh people can can can she wanted to know
because she's nosy
uh can they the players they can't see
those
people in the stands can they no they're
urgent too yeah they see the same they
see that the gummy is the screen
there's a screen it's a scream but they
see faces
they see everything the same thing i was
just asking maybe they were super
imposing for the people at home
it's not so much it's like it's like in
baseball you know you can look in the
stands but not see anything when they
have those
all those fans in the stands education
have you ever been on a pack like that's
a dumb question it is a dumb question
have you ever been on a conference call
in the last since the pandemic gets
started
what do you mean a zoom call a comcast
call yeah but i'm talking you know like
shaq's in the stands do they only see
that at home was my question goodness
they see the screen okay thank you ernie
they actually say
don't try to embarrass me don't call me
dumb on television